today I want to check out the City of
Light sick it's not far from Berlin and
it's set to be the most up-and-coming
city in eastern Germany
like tick has a reputation of being a
young hip and exciting city some even
call it the better Berlin actually live
six population is one of the youngest in
the entire country
and at last count it grew by 10,000 in
only one year they can all be crazy so I
came out here to find out what it is
that makes this city so fascinating the
central train station is the perfect
place to begin a tour of leipzig because
the main terminus is already quite an
attraction the concourse is enormous
with endless shopping possibility my
first stop is colleague connect Strasse
the epicenter for the city's youth
culture
lies at the edge of the city center and
is affectionately referred to as Carly
you can get there in no time by tram the
street has undergone quite a bit of
renovation but fortunately some
buildings have managed to maintain their
original charm be sure to spend some
time browsing in the many weird and
wonderful shops you'll find here
concerts open-air theatre and workshops
also regularly take place on Carly
fine costs and work to are especially
popular venues
Leipzig is invoke everybody's talking
about its resurgence but what do the
people who actually live here say I
thought a good place to find out would
be the local university campus appendage
to Denton katoya history culture here is
great it's home and welcoming become
dandy Ricky Ricky and the nightlife is
fantastic I love the carne it's a good
place to bar - like we mentioned people
who live here are different than in
other places they're a bit more open
more tolerant I really like it in keV
head Mia said with you your rooms Plaza
I was enticed by the affordable rent the
nightlife and the whole scenes and koota
Xena how much we looked right next to
the university is mullets bust tight the
only remaining part of lightsticks
ancient town fortifications converted
into a cultural center it has become an
institution among the city's hotspots
it's where I've arranged to meet Matt
and vaga an expert on leipzig
socio-political evolution Manton goes to
the university and works at a
student-run radio station
let's see you tell me how did you end up
in Leipzig Lana PIM I came here after
army training I'd done four years with
the Bundeswehr and wanted to study so I
came here to enroll at the University
Vijay haggle what should i do we need
Ella I think what did I like to have
that other cities don't I'm feeling lots
of young people the student population
is around 40,000 guy and then there's
another 10,000 don't trainee your
apprenticeship positions lots of young
tourists come here as well so all in all
the atmosphere here is really unique
let's - what lighting is often compared
to Berlin yeah ma plays Leipzig starting
to rival the capital and if so in what
way yeah life is release under thousand
times it isn't trying to compete
constitute you can't really compare
cities Berlin is Berlin Leipzig is live
tonight since does its own thing we're
not really cosmopolitan we're not giving
oku to of
fashion a run for its money with our own
labels what we do have is a youthful
vibe a lively scene lots of startups and
young entrepreneurs who inject a lot of
energy into the city mikage has a
completely different vibe than Berlin
plus a baton you mentioned the scene so
where are the hip neighborhood scene a
bit so that's why I'm Devin the western
part of the city is really happening in
terms of arts and culture and in the
south the block fits neighborhood is
where the counterculture is claps do you
think there are downsides to the city
changing naturally of course you can't
avoid the gentrification issue in
Leipzig you can still find spacious
apartments to rent for 180 euros a month
which is about the lowest in Germany but
there's also a lot of construction going
on things are getting more expensive
about ask about the business executives
and people with high incomes are moving
in who are used to and expect a
different standard of living people with
alternative lifestyles who don't want to
pay much rent are being priced out nor
you believe in born on the Avena
commuted sign one um
wall thing what do you think Leipzig
will be like in 10 years time the sluice
of us you see it in the worst case
scenario would be that there are no more
young people here and only professionals
in their mid-30s working for global
players yup I didn't globally play on
our baton boil a balance would be ideal
that the city would be attractive to
both young people and to people who like
a higher standard of living cnc thank
you very much
Jenna nice propose yeah hopefully with
Sunita nice cheese touch
and here's another landmark the monument
to the Battle of the nations known by
locals as the funky it's surrounded by a
park
and right here I'm gonna try something
really cool urban golfing hello is
because our oyster ones are welcome to
our urban golfing session in life see
urban golfing is like golf but with a
major difference we're not trying to get
the ball into a tiny hole we're aiming
at a larger target like this one's
buzzing
urban golf balls are also lighter than
regular ones that means you can't hit
the mass bar and you don't have to walk
so much
so we start with a warm-up picnic the
pop seems League on my brains the club
over your shoulders and turn from side
to side now a few basic tips or
detecting hold your index finger like a
gun wound fee more but Beauty is it a
little uncomfortable come on
yeah done then you're doing it right
katyaaa makes the perfect shot time for
me to try my luck
hmmm I think I need a few more tips when
Dan was all still trying I followed the
same line when he started swing the club
and follow through towards the ball
Lauren we're ready for our first game
the others are looking pretty good
unlike me we play a few holes some of
our targets are man-made others are 100%
natural and then it's time for the
awards horn plot science first place
goes to the person who needed the fewest
shots to hit the targets Janine
congratulations well done
Nicole you get the consolation prize
with the golfer on it hmm hmm voices
just like me today after that I think I
deserve a break
lightstick is hardly a seaside town and
he's yet it's where you'll find the
longest sandy beach in all of Saxony on
the shores of Lake Coast food just half
an hour from the center of town it's a
man-made lake like many others in this
region it's really nice here another
plus point for lipstick
I'm going to treat myself to a lovely
sunset before throwing myself into the
party scene
light steaks nightlife the choice of
bars and clubs is mind-boggling one of
the hottest spots at the moment is
called fantastic
in all honesty even after the time I
spend here it's impossible for me to say
what's better berlin nor lies eclectic
is definitely different in other words a
little raw and rough around the edges
not quite ready to settle and i think
that is exactly what makes life tick so
special